ne serions nous pas en plein mois de
juin au moment de tourner cette vidéo on
est en juin 2021
bienvenue à tous si vous arrivez du
futur et enjoint 2025 est une
compétition qui se passe ça s'appelle
l'euro l'euro 2020 en juin 2021 je sais
qu'on n'a pas en train de voyager dans
le temps mais c'est bien pourtant comme
ça que ça se passe cette année et qu'est
ce qui se passe car les grandes
compétitions sportives et bien beaucoup
de personnes vient de changer leur
téléviseur pour trouver une telle est de
meilleure qualité pour pouvoir regarder
notamment les matchs de foot c'est un
petit peu ce qui se passe quand il ya
des grandes compétitions notamment
l'euro et la coupe du monde bon cette
année vous avez la chance et l'euro il
ya les jo derrière
donc ça c'est bien donc à plein de ce
sport est donc aujourd'hui on vient se
parle et de quoi on vient se parer d'un
téléviseur et d'une marque pas n'importe
laquelle s'appelle hisense parce qu'en
plus de 500 et partenaires de l'euro
2020 n'oubliez pas vos manches cette
vidéo nous sommes en juin 2021 by un
petit peu dans le temps et ça fait un
petit moment pour discuter avec hisense
et qu'on s'est dit que ça serait bien
présente un de vos produits et scène ce
qu'on regarde ça qu'on voit ce que vous
savez faire est ce que ça marche ça
marche parce que c'est intéressant alors
je vous le dis tout de suite
d'entrée de jeu franco sharief saeid il
ya une ghana est tellement large
elle est très large elle est très grande
ici on est sur un produit d'entrée de
gamme dans le cul l'aide dans le quantum
dots plutôt aussi accès gaming un
téléviseur qui coûtent moins de 700
euros d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je
vous mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil on va regarder ce qui est bien on
a gardé les limites ont interdit ce
qu'il sait faire ce qu'il sait pas faire
il saura pas tout faire à moins de 700
euros il ne sera pas tout faire à boire
à manger vous servir faire votre lit
vous bercer et vous comptez des comtés
unis ne saura pas tout faire par contre
c'est faire des choses il les fait quand
même plutôt bien dans l'ensemble
on va donc sans regarder ça on a
également parlé aussi de la télécommande
à bord un beau téléviseur c'est bien
avoir une bonne expérience et bien c'est
encore mieux donc on va regarder
l'expérience globale ont regardé l'écran
de regarder la dame malade et ce qu'elle
propose de regarder le pouvoir garder le
pied on aura dit plein de choses mais ça
c'est cool ça ça ça me plaît
[Musique]
et j'attends que j'aime bien c'est ce
design avec des petits bords ça c'est un
point positif
hisense est pas seul à le faire mais on
le retrouve ici sur une télé à moins de
700 euros une fois de plus c'est bien on
a débord qui sont quand même
relativement fin des pieds qui sont très
légers une télé qui est en cours
vraiment bien profilée petit logo xn son
milieu elle est sympa tous les côtés et
ça c'est vrai que ça marche
alors puisque je vous parle des pieds
ils sont hyper facile à monter vous avez
de vis de wisla de wisla bon en fait
vous avez quatre vis mais extrêmement
simple avis est remonté le truc qui est
assez sympa ici ils sont nus planquer
ces du point de détail à vous et des
petits passages pour vos câbles à
l'intérieur ce qui fait que vous allez
éviter d'avoir des câbles qui passe en
plein milieu vous avez également un
petit passage de câbles dans le pied qui
est planqué juste là alors c'est pas
parfait complet moi ici je suis un peu
tendu derrière ce qui fait que ça ne le
passent pas complètement la neige peut
le faire plonger en tout cas ça va
éviter d'avoir des câbles en plein
milieu c'est pas trop mal si assez
ingénieux et ça fera le taf
alors puisqu'on est là on regarde de ce
côté là tout de suite regardé en attaque
front de billets ici c'est la ligne
voilà côté droit c'est la lime côté
gauche vous avez 3 h david 2.1 dont une
hier c'est vous avez deux prises usb une
sortie optique tout ce qu'il faut pour
bien branché câble et satellite du un
gie 45 de l'entrée audio une sortie
casque
enfin ici c'est assez complet bon par
contre il n'ya pas triste péritel mais
qui fait encore des prises péritel
aujourd'hui en 2021 je sais même pas
pourquoi je vous parle de christelle ça
n'a strictement aucun notaire et quand
on parle qu l'aide
on parle surtout écran on parle qualité
dalle on parle technologie c'est une
télé 4k uhd années 30 50 pouces ou le
format est un peu particulier j'étais
habitué plus aux 55 pouces
c'est du 50 pouces qui permet de rentrer
en fait et c'est assez intéressant fait
quand j'ai réfléchi vous allez pouvoir
rentrer dans des espaces qui peuvent
accueillir 1 55 pouces mais avec un
format un peu plus petit donc il va pas
venir empiéter lors dans certaines
configurations dans certaines maisons se
sera pas hyper optimale et on préférera
retrouvé un gros 55 pouces
ici c'est un poil plus petits la
diagonale est pas mal c'est du 127 cm
moi j'avais une autre télé ici avant 55
pouces c'est un poil plus petit mais
c'est pas très dérangeant ça dépend une
fois de plus des intérieurs pour les
personnes qui veulent mettre un format
autour de 50 pouces mais qui ne peuvent
pas mettre à 55 pouces et bien et
pourront la logique ça pour venir se
loger dans pas mal d'intérieur qui
étaient limités au niveau de la taille
55 pouces alors ici on va retrouver un
peu les technos standard on est
compatible hd rnis plus de mise
qu'est ce que ça vient nous apporter
tout ça est bien traitement de l'image
qui va être optimisée des meilleurs
contrastes meilleure gestion de la
lumière meilleure gestion des couleurs
des couleurs compatible à 10 bits avec
c'est un peu compliqué tous ces chiffres
là est un peu imbitable ce que ça va
vous permettre en fait d'abord derrière
c'est une optimisation grâce à un
algorithme avec de l'intelligence
artificielle pour avoir de meilleurs
résultats et pour avoir des images
optimisé en plus de ça derrière vous
avez ce qu'on appellera un upscaling en
4k
si vous avez du contenu en full hd qui
s'affiche ici on va venir le monte en
qualité pour qui s'affiche qualité 4 cas
sur votre téléviseur bien que la source
ne soit pas en 4k et vous avez une
techno qui s'appelle le quantum dots
color qui vous permettra de monter
jusqu'à 1 milliard de couleurs alors
c'est pas un milliard de couleurs
différentes c'est un milliard de nuances
de couleurs mais parce qu'on n'a pas un
milliard de couleurs si vous regardez
une palette de couleurs n'est pas un
milliard couleurs mais par contre est
plein de petites nuances des nuances de
rouge des nuances degrés est et nuances
de vert et l'idée tout et nuancé que ça
apportait plus de précisions en image
plus juste plus nette et plus agréable à
l'oeil vous avez également une techno
qui s'appelle techno house pictures
optimization qui va venir optimisée et
l'audio et la vidéo avec de
l'intelligence artificielle derrière
dont vous avez compris on va rester en
tout cas un peu simple vous avez pas mal
de péquenots logis derrière qui vont
venir optimisé l'image pour rendre vos
sources beaucoup plus belles beaucoup
plus claire quelles qu'elles soient
alors après si vous êtes sur you tube
hey hey vous n'êtes pas beaucoup de
bande passante et que ça vous fait de
l'espèce de gros cubes et que c'est pas
terrible ça passe à grand chose
il faut vous ayez de la bande passante
il faut vous ayez une belle source une
qualité à la base qu'ils soient bien
mais après derrière la télévision va
bien faire le boulot pour me remonter
tout ça en qualité alors c'est pas
magique non plus attention on est sur
une télé qui coûtent moins de 700 euros
on n'a pas autant technologique sur une
autre télé de hisense ou l'autre qui va
coûter 1500 2000 voir un petit peu plus
voire même beaucoup plus donc on va pas
avoir les meilleurs techno mais
néanmoins ici et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que pour voir qu'on est dans un
budget à un peu moins de 700 euros on a
des techno derrière on l'a et techno qui
sont là pour améliorer l'image pour
rendre l'expérience de visionnage bien
meilleur c'est pas trop mal
ce que je veux me reprocher un peu ici
c'est que je trouve que les noirs sont
un peu trop poussif
alors vous avez des réglages on peut
venir gratouiller un peu dans ses
réglages pour venir moduler ça mais
quand vous le prenez comme ça nativement
il vient toucher un peu plus noir pour
vous racheter du contraste faut que
c'est un peu trop il faut venir dans vos
réglages vous changer ça vous adapter
peut-être que vous aimerez vous moi je
trouve ça un petit peu trop
plus il en faut pour tout le monde et
pour tous les goûts et surtout derrière
comme vous prévenir dans les réglages
on peut changer et c'est bien donc ça
c'est cool comme je vous parlais thaler
d'euros de football de sport en règle
générale alors l'euro va passer je sais
pas s'ils vont râler cette vidéo moment
où il ya l'euro ont peut-être après peu
importe leur dites le moi vous n'êtes
quand tout de suite vous êtes en quel
moment vous êtes dans le futur vous êtes
dans le passé marqué le mois on va aux
commentaires comme on parle d' euros ici
un autre sport alors le mode sport
qu'est ce qu'il va venir faire et bien
bien venir optimiser les images c'est un
compensateur mouvement qui va être
couplé au mode sport
l'idée lorsque vous allez regarder un
match de foot eh bien ça va venir
permettre d'avoir plus de détails
apporter plus de fluidité lorsque vous
allez venir regarder alors ici on est un
maximum en 60 r ça on est pas en sens
inverse mais ça a bien malgré tout
augmenter l'expérience et en plus de ça
est séparé de le dire vous avez une
certification tuv rheinland ce qu'ils
veulent être votre télé elle est
certifiée lutter contre la lumière bleue
ça pourrait paraître presque du point de
détail mais vous avez un capteur
luminosité qui va venir adapté
l'affichage de votre téléviseur par
rapport à la lumière ambiante de votre
pièce est forcément si vous êtes en
plein jour qu'il ya du soleil
vous n'allez pas vouloir afficher la
même chose que si vous êtes dans une
ambiance tamisée regarder un film
détendu le soir donc la télé de l'avenir
s'adapter à ça et vous permettent il
faut être plus d'augmenter l'expérience
de visionnage
si vous êtes un gamer vous avez un autre
jeu mais il faut raccorder un pc ou une
console de jeu pour revenir l'activer
c'est pas le cas je suis pas gay mais
j'ai pas le matos mais en tout cas vous
pouvez bien le faire que ça vous
permettra de faire ça et bien c'est de
diminuer l'input lag donc d'être encore
plus dans votre jeu il est beaucoup plus
réactif à ce que va venir jouer à
différentes parties à différents je
voyais un truc qui m'a un peu surpris
avec ce télévision lorsque j'ai reçu le
carton lorsque je les portais lorsque je
vais installer c'est qu'en fait j'ai un
chauffeur qui arrive avec un
semi-remorque qui le garde devant la
porte et qui me dit non mais c'est bon
pour les profits tout seul a lancé léger
est en fait la télé en elle même elle
fait 11 kilos on est un peu moins de
quinze kilos je prends avec l'emballage
barre encore un tout petit peu moins
mais on skie l'eau ce qui fait que j'ai
pas besoin de dire à 2 personnes pour le
porter pour l'installer c'est pas mal
devient de chaque côté mais moi je les
portais je l'installé tout seul ça se
fait super bien donc ça c'est vraiment
agréable de se dire ok j'ai pas besoin
d'appeler un pote avons appelé la
famille d'accueil qui que ce soit pour
venir l'installer je la prends ta
déplacer si j'ai besoin de venir faire
notre hôte à nettoyer parce que oui
effectivement des fois on veut venir
tout en lui pour faire le grand ménage
de printemps
eh bien on l'apprend que tu on l'enlève
on la dépose ça c'est très facile 11 kg
pas mal qu'est ce qui se passe par
contre ici au niveau audio et bien vous
avez deux haut parleurs de 10 watts
alors on ajoutera que c'est pas ici
qu'on va voir le sont les plus dingues
hausse est pas là où c'est à dire crash
est le max pourquoi pas mettre une
petite barre de son en complément
n'empêche
hisense aller jeter un coup d'oeil sur
leur site vous avez en plus du dolby
atmos pour l expérience et pour
l'immersion à 360 degrés c'est une
sensation d'immersion attention une fois
de plus il vous faudrait un système un
peu plus complet mais c'est vrai que là
avec les deux haut parleurs de 10 watts
a fait le taf le spectre est à
s'équilibrer
il ya un beau travail qui a été fait la
suze d'en reconnaître donc l'expérience
audio là dessus est bonne vous n'avez
pas besoin de venir l'augmenter si vous
voulez l'augmenter vous pouvez pour
ajouter en immersion en spécialisation
mais telle qu'elle est là ça fait le
boulot on a avec ici une petite
télécommande alors je voulais tout de
suite c'est pas la télécommande la plus
dingue que j'ai pu rencontrer
elle est complète c'est une certitude
elle est un peu épaisses mais une fois
de plus leur position par rapport aux
tarifs un petit peu moins de 700 euros
dont bon voilà ça va elle fait son taf
de télécommande ni plus ni moins on a
effectivement et vous le voyez tous les
boutons peut venir choisir votre source
ici avec l'input de quoi venir naviguer
ici le volume l'échelle pour coter au
monde va parler d'expérience avec vitaa
ressasser les os on en parle dans
quelques instants
vous avez un petit micro pour venir
parler à google ou alors à massoud avec
ça vous appuyez vous venez lui susurrer
des mots doux à l'oreille donc ça c'est
plutôt cool
vous allez pouvoir ensuite retrouver les
sous titres compagnie sas ailier invita
tous des contenus gratuits du sport
c'est écrit en anglais c'est un peu
dommage mais bon voilà c'est comme ça et
puis des petits raccourcis alors ça
c'est plutôt rare d'en voir autant en
règle générale sur les télécommandes et
bien vous avez youtube ou netflix voir
prime voir a coûté mais pas tous comme
ça donc là vous avez la compet même
molotov tébessa c'est vachement bien
super application pour me regarder des
films des séries enregistrait compagnie
et puis ici médias si vous avez un truc
médias sur votre box par exemple qui
revient coûtait pourquoi pas ici
l'expérience logiciel c'est évident a
fait d'avoir à que la chanteuse qui a
quasiment le même temps l'expérience
elle équipera hypra simple sur le hall à
vouloir me rechercher changer de source
ou choisissez un vos différentes sources
et compagnie ok ça ça marchera du hdmi
et compagnie votre télé bref comme vous
souhaitez vous avez ici vos différents
paramètres pourraient venir modifier un
petit peu l'image mode automatique
format de l'image et compagnie on peut
venir gratouiller ici ça peut être assez
intéressant s'il ya des choses qu'on
veut venir changer moi sur l'automatique
vous avez sport dynamique s'il aimait
nuit cinéma toujours le format de
l'image du 16/9 du 4/3 paramétrage de
mode d'image et là vous verrez modifier
la luminosité le contraste la saturation
des couleurs
le contraste adaptatif oui ou non la
compensation des mouvements net ou pas
la réduction de bruit numérique en
fonction de ce qui va s'afficher en
fonction de ce que vous avez la
température des couleurs et même les
paramètres experts
là il faut quand même s'y connaître un
petit peu plus voyez mais on peut venir
gratouiller pas mal de choses si on
commence à s'y connaître un petit peu
sur les réglages des couleurs sur la
balance des blancs
on peut venir le faire des réglages
aussi au niveau de l'audio dois bien me
voyez qui est activée ici vous
choisissez votre réseau internet
la recherche de chaînes automatique
toutes les questions d'accessibilité le
système et l'assistance
bon je veux pas ça c'est très simple et
ça fonctionne très très bien et ensuite
vous avez des grands grands grands
standards netflix youtube prime vidéo
molotov rmc salto et compagnie vous avez
des applications beaucoup d'applications
pour venir régler par vous même et
ensuite vous retrouvez-vous différents
contenus des films et cetera des matchs
et compagnie je vous passe un petit peu
tout le détail ce qui est intéressant
savoir ici c'est que si vous le
souhaitez il ya pouvait venir installer
des jeux directement ici vous allez dans
my apps et vous ai pas mal
d'applications à venir installer en plus
youtube qui traînent multi vie vous avez
la météo vous avez votre catalogue
d'applications de vida oui vous venez
choisir après un par thématique jeux
enfants musique et compagnie vous avez
un catalogue qui est conséquent avec pas
mal d'applications à venir installer ici
ensuite vous avez plein de petits jeux
si vous êtes un amoureux vous trouvez
des petits jeux un petit peu rigolo de
l'arcade et compagnie vous en avez bon
après le mieux pour revenir je vois tu
s'il te brancher une console et un pc et
d'utiliser vos télés comme un moniteur
et comme je vous le disais si vous avez
les assistants google vous appuyez sur
vos télécommandes et voulue par les
ouvres netflix et voilà c'est simple
vous avez essayé du wifi dual band vous
avez du bluetooth si vous lui accordez
un casque sans fil vous pouvez le faire
va y aller il ya pas mal d'options on a
toutes les options qu'on doit attendre
d'une télé connectée aujourd'hui en 2021
à un tarif à moins de 700 euros le
résultat je trouve vraiment convenable
il ya ces petits réglages à venir voire
peut-être que vous ça vous dérangera pas
cette question des noirs qui sont un
petit peu trop présents mais une fois de
plus pour venir tout régler ici dans vos
paramètres et si vous êtes curieux et si
elle vous intéresse tous les liens
photos en bas dans la description ça
fait un petit moment que je voulais vous
parler de cette marque cette marque est
un des leaders qui est encore
aujourd'hui assez peu connu en france
qui se fait de plus en plus connaître et
on le voit notamment au travers de
grandes compétitions comme l'euro 2020
qu'on retrouve en 2021
c'est un peu compliqué mais klokobetz a
mis un peu le bazar c'est une marque
sérieuse qui propose beaucoup de
produits d'électroménager pour votre
maison c'est qu'elle est là et
intéressante
on n'ira pas aussi loin que soit pouvoir
retrouver avec d'autres produits une
fois de plus de 100 à plus de mille
balles mais ça c'est normal pour moi le
gros point fort ici ce avec le format 50
pouces un peu plus petit du 55 pouces
donc pour certains intérieurs ça ira
parfaitement bien l'expérience logiciel
qui est vraiment correct
un affichage de bonne qualité
l'expérience audio je trouve vraiment
intéressante donc on a un produit qui
est vraiment équilibré on a beaucoup de
connectique derrière et le point
également intéressant et bien c'est le
tarif qui est quand même relativement
bas a vous de me dire vous ce que vous
entendez cette télé et une fois de plus
tous les liens sont bas voilà sur ce je
vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt et
puis si vous l'avez acheté dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires faites moi un petit retour
d'expérience avez vous remarqué tout ça
bien évidemment en bas on commentaire
vous prenez soin de vous des bisous de
l'amour et à très bientôt
à très bientôt ciao